do you think Cheeto is the best dressed
in the UFC stop I'm being dead serious
Cheeto has fantastic style we had this
conversation last time I don't know what
you have with Cheeto I don't know my man
has great style it has nothing to do
with me wanting to you know knock his
ass out I just genuinely don't look at
him be like I think it's [__] up what
you do to Gotham City on a day-to-day
basis but I like that is kind of [__]
up you really think he dress is nice huh
no [__] I think he has great style
for like
what I mean not to be a
kaleidoscope
but you got Top Ramen on your head
let's who other than you has good style
in you um obviously Conor dress Conor
style I'm not as I'm into Conor but the
style I don't yeah yeah so
gay I just like him like him as a
man